TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show."
Today we're at the
Android Dev Summit
at the Computer History Museum
in Mountain View, California,
just down the road
from where Android
was started 10
years ago and where
it's still developed today.
As usual with these
summits, all the sessions
are recorded and
available online,
but that's a ton of
content if you want
to just get the highlights.
So here you are the
Android Dev Summit Top 5.
Number 0, we're engineers.
We get to do that.
But seriously this is a
bit of a meta highlight.
What struck me most
about the keynote
was how often everyone on stage
referred to developer feedback.
SPEAKER 1: Your feedback.
SPEAKER 2: The feedback.
SPEAKER 3: Feedback.
SPEAKER 4: Feedback.
SPEAKER 5: Feedback.
SPEAKER 6: Feedback.
SPEAKER 7: Feedback.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This team is
amazing at taking feedback
and putting it into
the platform roadmap.
In his introduction,
Dave Burke even
referred to the Android
platform as a powerful SDK
that puts developers first.
And I think we saw
that throughout all
the announcements.
Anyhow, number 1, app bundles.
They're now stable and
available in Google Play
and, on average, apps are
seeing a 35% size savings
compared to a universal APK.
Also Instant Apps
are now supported
as part of app
bundles, so you can now
upload one bundle for both
instant and installed apps.
And dynamic feature modules
are now available for testing.
They let you load
modules on demand
to make the core
APK even smaller.
Number 2, the Google
Play in-app updates API.
It allows you to trigger
updates within your app
either with a blocking flow,
where the user is expected
to apply the update right
away, or a flexible update,
where it doesn't need to
be updated immediately.
Now some of us have built
similar flows on our own
before, but this is a
standard implementation,
which is easier to use.
Now for number 3, Kotlin 1.3.
Kotlin became a first-class
language for Android last year,
and it's an awesome way
to develop for Android.
This latest version
includes new features
such as inline classes,
unsigned numbers,
and perhaps most importantly,
coroutines support
is now stable.
If you haven't had a chance
to dig in with Kotlin yet,
there's one more thing
they unveiled for it
at the summit
that'll interest you,
a preview of the new
Udacity course on Android
app development in Kotlin
using Jetpack as well as
other popular
third-party libraries.
Fourth on our list is the
updates to Android Jetpack.
I think it's so
cool that it's now
being developed in
the open on public
AOSP, which means we can
all now see features and bug
fixes as they're
developed and contribute
to any of the libraries.
Also the Architecture
Components libraries
that were announced
at I/O with Jetpack
will be in beta
later this month.
Work manager is for
background tasks,
and navigation uses
integrated tooling in studio
to simplify in-app navigation.
Our last one, number 5.
You know it has to
be foldable devices.
These are very cool
and totally make sense
on Android, which
is a platform that
has supported
different screen sizes
and densities for a long time.
The killer feature here
is screen continuity,
which means starting an
experience on the folded
smaller screen,
and as you unfold,
it seamlessly transfers
to the bigger screen.
The team is adding
resizable flags
so apps can respond to
folding and unfolding.
That's it, your Android
Dev Summit Top 5.
For more announcements
and updates,
click the links in
the description below.
And on your way
there, take a second
to click that Like button,
that Subscribe button,
and share this video
with your friends.
They'll thank you for
it, and we'll thank you
by doing more of them.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show,"
and I'll see you
at the next summit.